on en parlait en début d'émission le
lancement d'une nano satellite inspire 7
seven a une nouvelle fois été repoussée
conçue par le laboratoire atmosphère et
observation spatiale le à laboratoire
atmosphère et observation spatiale oui
le l'Atmos il a pour objectif d'observer
le Soleil et la Terre et de nous donner
des informations sur le climat et
notamment sur les réchauffements
climatiques mais ça date de mise en
orbite ne cesse d'être reportée pour en
parler avec nous Philippe quétude le
vice-président de l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin en Yvelines et
Mustapha mefta le responsable du
programme petit satellite alors inspire
set seven devait se lancer ce matin aux
alentours de 8h30 que s'est-il passé
pourquoi pourquoi est-ce qu'il ne s'est
pas élancé
alors on peut dire c'est que le
satellite il dépend de la fusée et lui
il est il est dans sa coiffe lui ne
bouge pas donc lui il attend d'être
éjecter donc c'est la fusée elle-même
qui qui a bon qui a eu un problème pas
majeur mais voilà c'est l'habitude alors
on entend pas parler mais ça existe
toujours là c'est un défaut technique
qui est mineur comme j'ai expliqué en
début de séance bon à un moment une
série de tests est mis en place pour
vérifier que tout normalement doit bien
se passer et là une anomalie une
anomalie a été détectée alors vous savez
parfois on nous avons des informations
qui correspondent à des réponses
précises et puis à d'autres moments il y
a des choses qui peuvent être un peu
plus confidentielles liées à des
activités de sécurité ou de défense
nationale notamment pour les Américains
parce que la particularité de ce
lancement c'est que on va se rappeler
que du coup la fusée est lancée d'une
base militaire en Californie donc pour
le précédent satellite on nous avons
fait un lancement depuis la Floride
c'était le 21
le 24 janvier 2021 avec le lancement du
vsq7 et pour ce tir nous partons depuis
une base militaire en Floride donc ça
Vandenberg et c'est environ à une
centaine de kilomètres au nord de Los
Angeles alors pour la petite histoire
quand même un autre satellite française
a été lancé depuis cette base un des
premiers satellites français qui
s'appelait FR1 il avait été lancé en
1965 donc c'est une longue histoire
entre la France et les États-Unis
d'Amérique vis-à-vis notamment de ce
genre de coopération dans la mise en
orbite de satellites et donc là a priori
il s'agirait d'un problème technique
venant de SpaceX de la fusée SpaceX
et d'ailleurs ce que peut rajouter c'est
cuvsq7 qui a été envoyé en 2021 donc et
qui va fonctionner avec inspire ça de 7
donc pour nous c'est important a été
repoussé aussi trois fois donc voilà on
n'est pas dans dans un actualité qui qui
met en doute notre programme c'est
relativement habituel alors bon ça met
toujours de la tension parce que voilà
un lancement de satellite c'est toujours
voilà un peu à Paris au décollage en la
mise en orbite qui sont des phases
toujours critiques alors est-ce que vous
pouvez quand même un petit peu vous
expliquer quelles sont les conditions
nécessaires pour qu'un anneau satellite
un satellite puisse bien décoller avec
une fusée
la première chose c'est de c'est de
développer ce satellite qu'il devienne
performant et qu'il respecte certaines
conditions bon une des conditions c'est
la tenue au vibrations ensuite la tenue
à l'environnement en température et
après il y a une grosse partie associée
à la législation donc un départ en
premier paramètre pour nous c'est le
droit le droit spatial et pour nous
c'est un satellite donc français donc on
doit respecter la législation française
dès lors on se met en accord avec SpaceX
pour répondre à une multitude de
paramètres pour que le satellite puisse
être mis en orbite on le livre aux
États-Unis et ensuite on est en attente
alors quand même une petite
particularité dans le cas de SpaceX
c'est qu'il lance une multitude disons
une multitude de lanceurs et depuis le
début de l'année ils ont déjà fait plus
d'une quinzaine de lancement donc des
décalages sont possibles initialement ce
lancement comme vous l'avez dit en début
de séance c'était prévu en janvier
23 donc pour nous c'est trois mois de
décalage et c'est très difficile pour
les équipes parce que on s'est beaucoup
de stress beaucoup de tensions donc pour
ma part ce sont des des échanges la nuit
vu que nous avons 9 heures de décalage
et typiquement pour le pour le lancement
du mardi 12 avril bon moi j'ai eu
l'information à 4h du matin et puis
c'est difficile de prévenir les
personnes donc j'ai attendu le matin
pour annoncer la la quelque part la
mauvaise nouvelle les gens étaient un
peu déçus parce que tout le monde veut
voir à un moment cet événement et puis
bon par ailleurs c'est aussi très bien
de le voir sur place parce que assistant
lancement en direct c'est c'est autre
chose alors pour la mission de ce
satellite est-ce que ça va changer
quelque chose qu'il soit envoyé trois
mois plus tard ou
ça ne va rien changer au final
je peux répondre et puis que tu veux
partager tous les deux la réponse
bon pour nous plus vite c'est lancé
mieux c'est parce que nous avons déjà un
autre satellite qui en orbite et le
satellite USA a été développé
initialement pour avoir une durée de vie
d'une année donc comme vous l'avez vu ça
fait plus de 2 ans que c'est en orbite
donc c'est quand même une réussite pour
le laboratoire pour la recherche
françaises et aussi pour le territoire
parce que nous avons poussé un nombre
d'entreprises du territoire pour pouvoir
réaliser cet instrument le deuxième à
partir du moment où il est mis en orbite
il faut aussi que le premier reste
vivant le plus longtemps possible et
avec deux satellites on est en train de
mettre en place une constellation puis
je vais laisser mon collègue donner la
suite parce que ça va nous intéresser au
niveau des variables climatiques
essentielles que l'on cherche à observer
notamment pour de la multi-mesure oui
parce que ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
scientifiquement le fait qu'on est comme
ça des constellations c'est on apporte
beaucoup plus que avoir un seul
satellite aujourd'hui on a besoin de
précision on a besoin de résolution
spat mal temporelle et donc un passage
ne suffit pas il faut il faut pouvoir
avoir plusieurs satellites alors bien
sûr celui-ci est envoyé dans une orbite
différente donc ils m'ont pas passé au
même heure ils vont compléter ce que
faisait le premier satellite et donc ça
ça va être une première c'est vraiment
de montrer que un plusieurs satellites
scientifiquement apporte plus
aujourd'hui on est dans une dans une
course quand même sur les problèmes
climatiques et notamment de comprendre
des cycles courts parce que même si
c'est le climat en fait finalement les
processus ils sont ils sont courts et
régionales donc il faut qu'on puisse
voilà pavé l'ensemble du alors ce qui
est bien c'est que ce satellite qu'on
envoie il couve la terre entière il
s'arrête pas lui il tourne mais il en
faut plusieurs pour pouvoir voilà avoir
heure par heure ce qui va se passer quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il va apporter concrètement
comme information pour je vais répondre
alors en termes d'information plus
plusieurs paramètres vont nous
intéresser bon déjà un des paramètres
qui est fondamental c'est le
déséquilibre énergétique de la terre
c'est comment la planète accumule de
l'énergie donc il faut savoir que la
majeure partie de l'énergie est
accumulée dans les océans donc c'est
important de savoir quelle énergie nous
accumulons et comment un moment nous
allons évoluer vers par exemple
meilleure connaissance de la température
pour les 50 à 60 prochaines années donc
l'intérêt des satellites c'est de faire
des mesures précises pour consolider des
modèles climatiques et à partir du
moment où les modèles climatiques sont
mieux maîtrisés on a une meilleure idée
des températures à venir donc ça c'est
l'aspect modélisation et l'autre
paramètre ça va être l'atténuation
quelle solution nous allons pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre pour pouvoir répondre à
ces problématiques donc ça c'est
indépendant du programme un autre c'est
par exemple d'observer la ionosphère
d'une sphère c'est une des couches de
l'atmosphère donc mieux comprendre ce
qu'il peut se produire en termes de
perturbation donc pour cela nous avons
une coopération avec l'ONERA qui a un
grand organisme des plus grands
organismes au niveau aéronautique et
spatial en France
qui va étudier ces phénomènes et c'est
important pour les perturbations au
niveau des communications vous avez vu
que nous sommes de plus en plus dans un
monde hyper technologique alors ça a des
gros avantages mais aussi des fragilités
parce que nous sommes tributaires de ces
technologies et si pour X raisons si par
exemple nous avons une grosse tempête
Giovanni nous ne savons pas prévenir ce
genre de problème bon on peut avoir une
baisse ou une coupure de communication
donc c'est aussi important au niveau
local et régional d'avoir ces
informations ce qu'on peut ajouter quand
même malgré tout c'est ce que c'est que
la ionosphère la une sphère c'est cette
zone où circule justement les satellites
donc c'est en ça que c'est critiques
parce que effectivement si vous
satellites dysfonctionnent
tout le monde va s'en apercevoir on aura
pu te téléphone on aura plus de télé on
aurait pu grand chose voilà aujourd'hui
on est quand même très très dépendants
de la technologie et donc avoir ces
épisodes ça permet d'anticiper de couper
ponctuellement certaines connexions et
de préserver du coup les satellites et
alors dernière question est-ce que
l'actualité internationale la
géopolitique a joué un rôle aussi dans
le report du lancement de ce la nos
satellite la réponse c'est probable
alors nous nous sommes des chercheurs et
des scientifiques
forcément je pense notamment aux
tensions entre Taïwan
vis-à-vis de certaines informations
évidemment que certains événements
peuvent introduire des problématiques on
peut vous parler de brouillage ou de oui
c'est possible de ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que globalement je penétique nous
impacte de toute façon puisque le
spatial c'est quand même une affaire
très internationale et alors même si
nous là sur ces sur les projets dont on
parle ce sont des périodes relativement
courtes les autres projets ce sont des
projets effectivement à 10 ou 20 ans
donc voilà des projets avec la Russie on
en avait beaucoup et donc voilà il y a
des impacts forcément quand ça devient
plus compliqué voire pour l'instant très
compliqué et bien merci beaucoup
Philippe quéquette et Mustapha mefta
d'avoir accepté notre invitation suivra
donc de près le lancement de l'inspire
state seven il devrait s'élancer ce
vendredi 14 avril d'une base américaine
militaire en Californie on va donc
croiser les doigts pour que tout se
passe bien
sur YouTube sur quelle chaîne Youtube du
coup le l'Atmos celle du Atmos